لا تزال الحدود بين لبنان وإسرائيل
متوترة حيث أطلقت الحسبة صواريخ
على إسرائيل وردت إسرائيل
بضربات جوية ومدفعية منذ
الثامن من أكتوبر، في اليوم التالي
لهجوم حماس المفاجئ الذي أطلقه بالا على
إسرائيل بشكل يومي مع
مجموعات أخرى بما في ذلك حماس والفلسطينيين.
وتطلق حركة الجهاد الإسلامي أيضًا وابلًا من
الصواريخ وتحاول التسلل عبر
الحدود، وترد إسرائيل
باستهداف البنية التحتية لحزب الله، من بين أشياء أخرى، ويقر
حزب الله
بأن ما يقرب من 50 من مقاتليه
قتلوا في هذه المناوشات،
كما قُتل العديد من المدنيين اللبنانيين
وفقًا لـ  إلى
المنظمة الدولية للهجرة،
فر حوالي 29 ألف مدني من
المجتمعات على طول الحدود إلى مناطق أكثر أمانًا
شمالًا،
وتغذي المناوشات المستمرة على الحدود
المخاوف من أن الصراع في غزة قد يثير
صراعًا إقليميًا أوسع نطاقًا، نصحت السفارة الأمريكية يوم الجمعة
جميع المواطنين الأمريكيين بمغادرة
لبنان.  الآن، في حين أن الرحلات الجوية التجارية لا تزال
متاحة، فإن الولايات المتحدة هي أحدث
دولة تحث مواطنيها على المغادرة
بينما لا يزال بإمكانهم التلميح إلى أين ترى
الحسبة أن هذا الصراع قد
يأتي يوم الجمعة عندما من المقرر أن يلتزم
زعيم الجماعة ذو الكاريزما ولكن المنعزل حسن
ناسالا الصمت حتى الآن.
لإلقاء كلمة، أنا بن ويدمان مراسل سي إن إن
من بيروت